[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight we spent months now assessing
the corona virus pandemic mostly from a
medical standpoint we now know a lot
more about the virus than we did back in
march in february and we're grateful for
that facts are always better than
speculation but it's possible that in
doing that we've spent maybe too little
time considering the rest of the country
the many millions of Americans who will
never face serious health risks from
this virus so the question is and we
should be asking this a lot how are they
doing well more than 30 million of them
are now unemployed 30 million that is so
many people that it's hard to digest
what it means or what is going to mean
five years from now for some context
that is double the job loss from the
great recession of 2009 that took us ten
years to recover from and he never did
recover in fact the entire middle class
never recovered so how long will 30
million take that's a terrifying
question in fact it's too scary for many
of our leaders to consider it implicates
their judgments their policies so
they're determined to ignore that
question and they're even more
determined that you ignore it too you
were absolutely not allowed to think
about that much less talk about it
how many times in the last week have you
clicked on a video a friend sent only to
discover it has been deleted by YouTube
Google because it criticized the people
in charge we've never seen anything like
this in the history of our country it
used to be a free place we bragged about
it but it's happening and not just
online the police commissioner of New
York announced this week the political
protests have been banned in America's
biggest city how long have they been
banned well for as long as his boss bill
de blasio says they're banned so it
could be a while it's nice when voters
aren't allowed to criticize you as the
Commissioner explained that's the law
now quote these are laws that been
passed down through executive order yeah
got that passed through executive order
but wait
by definition executive orders aren't
passed no legislature signs off in them
they're ordered that's why they're
orders whatever details shut up
you'd think some civil libertarian judge
somewhere would do something about all
of this
they're always inventing new rights for
legal aliens usually the right to free
stuff at your expense or a lot of those
maybe we could get some of those rights
too but no you're just an American do
what you're told
Shelley Luthor has learned that lesson
in the hardest way Luthor owns a salon
in the city of Dallas in March she
closed her business the government told
her to she lost all of her income when
she shut it down because that's what our
leaders demanded and then she waited and
she waited and she waited and a month
later her business was still closed and
she was out of money finally she decided
she had no choice her back was against a
wall so in April 24th she reopened her
salon the government warned her not to
do that they sent her a citation she did
it anyway
Dallas salon owner Shelley Luthor balint
to remain open in defiance of state
orders tearing up a citation she
received I could be used as an example
or they'll go away or I don't know I'm
not gonna shut down I can be used as an
example Luther said she was assuming
that other business owners in Dallas
might follow her lead but the government
took notice they wanted her to be an
example to but in a very different way
police arrested Luther they dragged her
before a Dallas County judge called Eric
Moy and that was Luther's bad luck boy
is a deeply irresponsible person he is a
political hack he's a self-described
Democratic Party activist he once
circulated a chain letter denouncing
Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas as
a race traitor
Eric Moy lectured Shelly Luther about
how she was a bad person watch yourself
putting your own interest ahead of those
of the community in which you live but
they disrespected the executive orders
of the state the orders of the county of
this city pompous fool but he's got a
lot of power he's a judge and Shelley
Luthor was sitting before him Luthor to
her enormous credit was not intimidated
instead of groveling apologizing and
begging forgiveness which is what he
wanted she told the judge what was so
obviously true for people who don't have
salaries that are guaranteed by
taxpayers this lockdown as it continues
has been a catastrophe feeding my kids
is not selfish moy was unmoved by this
he's not worried about feeding his kids
he went to Harvard Law School a 2007
article in The Washington Post describes
this man as someone quote with a
weakness for Cuban cigars and the finest
steaks what a poser as a judge Moy has
continued to collect a salary of about a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
throughout the shutdown he can take that
forever he can't afford all the finest
steaks he wants at least until meat
supplies run out moy sentenced Luther to
a week behind bars so that's what's
going on in Dallas tonight small
business owners who are going under
these are people with employees who are
struggling to buy food are being
punished for the crime of earning a
living by authoritarian buffoons goons
who were living off their tax dollars
how's that for an arrangement meanwhile
and this is the best part actual
criminals are going free three weeks ago
the city of Dallas began releasing more
than a thousand inmates from the County
Jail some are in four serious felonies
authorities said they had no choice they
had to save the inmates from the virus
the very same virus that Shelley Luther
will likely be exposed
two in jail where she is now for trying
to earn an honest living it's hard to
believe any of this is real
unfortunately in Israel it's happening
right now